direction la grèce pays qui poursuit son
déconfinement après la réouverture des
sites archéologiques lundi dont
l'acropole celle des écoles pose
problème ir enseignants et étudiants
sont descendus dans la rue pour
protester contre la reprise scolaire ils
estiment que les conditions sanitaires
ne sont pas réunies les professeurs
protestent également contre les réformes
du secteur de l'éducation annoncé par le
gouvernement la première chose dont nous
avons besoin et un dialogue avec le
ministère de l'éducation
ce qu'il n'a jamais fait auparavant cela
devrait commencer maintenant
c'est l'occasion avec ces mobilisations
de convaincre le ministère que le
dialogue est nécessaire lorsque des
décisions aussi importantes sont prises
concernant les écoles les enseignants et
les élèves
maintenant avec la crise du coronavirus
ils nous disent qu'ils veulent mettre
des caméras dans nos salles de classe et
diffusée en direct ce qui se passe en
classe ce qui signifie que toute
interaction entre les enseignants et les
élèves se fera sur internet